today we're going to take a deep dive
into the man who pioneered the concept
of ESG he is the reason why Dylan
Mulvaney got a Bud Light he should
actually thank Larry Fink Larry Fink and
seven other people in 1988 start a
company called BlackRock if you've never
heard about it it's a 10 trillion
dollars of assets under management
company that's more than any country in
the world except for two ready China and
U.S 1999 he takes the company public
seven thousand percent return today if
you have a share in 1999 a black rock
that today you got seven thousand
percent of return and he's now sitting
around saying you know the concept of
ESG is being weaponized there's a lot of
people saying things about them Trump
tried to get close to them 2020.
Schwartzman said good things about him
when they parted ways Elon Musk on
January 16 tweeted he said the word s in
ESG stands for satanic and he's talking
about Larry Fink I don't think those
guys are best friends who knows that may
be the second fight after
and here's what the great Charlie Monger
said about him he says I think the world
of Larry Fink but I'm not sure I want
him to be my Emperor having said that
let's go learn a little bit more about
this man Larry Fink and BlackRock so
earlier this week a survey came out on
Central Bank digital currencies and
here's what it said the results show
that 93 of central banks are working on
a cbdc 18 of central banks said they're
likely to use acbd's in the future and
these Banks represent 82 percent of
world population and 94 of global
economic output so why is this important
well for me I'm a pretty paranoid guy
when it comes down to Investments I got
a lot of equities I got alternative
Investments I got some crypto I got
things and I got collectible cards but I
also own a lot of gold because for me I
like to control my money and this is why
we chose to work with our new sponsor
American Hartford gold it's a couple
things I like about these guys they got
thousands of reviews five star reviews
online they will ship the gold physical
gold or silver directly to your front
door you could even set it up with a
gold IRA if you got retirement funds
that you cannot afford to lose this
could be a time for you to call American
Heart for gold a precious metal dealer
you can trust tell them my Ascension
they'll give you up to five thousand
dollars worth of free silver on your
first order so either click on the link
below or call
866-939-6984 again
866-939-6984 or text award pbd to 65532
again text the word pbd to 65532 okay so
if you get value out of this video give
it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel let's get right into it Larry
Fink major in political science
originally wanted to get into politics
and make an impact he decides to get
into finance and starts working at first
Boston Investment Bank in 1976 excels as
a bond Trader very new compared to
equity trading top performer at first
Boston responsible for roughly a billion
dollars to the bank's bottom line a
billion to the bank's bottom line that's
a lot of money at that stage your career
identify the power of computers and
trading very early in 1986 something
happens life-changing
he loses a hundred million dollars he is
humiliated and he quits first Boston
after losing trust amongst his peers and
the market but at the time he was 36
years old this experience for him was a
life-changing in his investment
philosophy took him 18 months to decide
on what he wanted to do next think
wanted to start his own business but
needed investment money meets with Steve
Schwartzman from Blackstone and makes a
good impression they start a joint
venture called Blackstone financial
management in 1988 started making money
in two weeks by 1989 this is only a year
later Fink has 2.7 billion dollars of
money under management and by 1993 think
he had eight billion dollars of money
under management now this time Fink is
obsessed with risk management he became
a Pioneer in using statistical model and
algorithms to trade bonds by 1994
BlackRock was managing 53 billion
dollars the same year Schwartzman and
think had an internal dispute over math
methods of compensation and Equity Fink
wanted to share Equity with new hires to
lower Talent from Banks while
Schwartzman did not want to further
lower Bank Stone State think wanted to
leave but needed someone to buy
Schwartzman ownership PNC eventually
ends up buying out Blackstone the one
reputation Larry finketta at this time
is the fact that he knew how to
restructure toxic debt and that's not an
easy skill set to have and he had so
this area that he specialized it causes
Fink and BlackRock to become known as
the place to go to call for situations
of wanting to restructure toxic debt
BlackRock spends years developing risk
management software called lanin which
launched in 1999 the same year the
company went public offers Aladdin
software to clients around the world
December 2000 Congress passed
Commodities and Futures modernization
act Banning regulation on derivatives
big Advantage obviously for BlackRock
BlackRock acquires Merrill Lynch
Investment Management expanding its
retail and international presence so at
this point he's got his independent name
game he you know people know who he is
Blackrock Larry thing no longer with
Schwartzman then 2008 crisis comes so
this causes all the companies including
the government to consult with BlackRock
on what to do with the debt even Jamie
dimon called think for advice when the
government asked him to buy bear Stearns
so imagine the U.S government as big as
they are the country they're running
they've got all these options on who to
call to consult them on this crisis that
they're dealing with who do they call
Larry Fink from BlackRock and why Larry
Fink because they had to restructure
toxic debt with Lehman Brothers bear
Stearns and Freddie Mac and the next one
I remember this one because that was at
the dinner when the CEO of AIG you know
Bob and Moshe and the CFO David Herzog
were in Chicago adverts Carlton having
dinner they're talking about what
they're doing they collected 183 billion
dollars from the government which they
later on paid with 21 billion dollars of
Interest this next part if you remember
AIG was like the biggest company
everybody was talking about aigin and
all of a sudden the edge becomes the
most hated company so 2008 was a very
big year for these guys because in 2008
they were managing 1.3 trillion dollars
of assets compared to now 15 years later
10 trillion dollars so obviously he sees
this as an opportunity like look we
dominated this whole toxic you know debt
restructural Market what's the next
thing he sees ETFs as the next thing and
eventually they own the ntf market
matter of fact today they own 35 of all
ETF money is with BlackRock today so now
watch The Evolution he starts off and
while everybody else trying to do stocks
and equities this guy's like no I'm
going to go be a bond Trader literally
nobody says I want to be a bond Trader
this guy does that and then afterwards
he loses 100 million teams up with
Schwartzman make a bunch of money then
he says guys we got to split up then
he's like I don't know what I do next
then they go into learning how to
restructure toxic debt then ETFs and
like what do we do now guess who starts
knocking on their doors for help ready
the Federal Reserve calls him for help
in 2020 the Federal Reserve calls Larry
Fink and asked to help them with the FED
prop up the entire corporate bond market
by purchasing on the central bank behalf
when corporate bond rate Spike the
Federal Reserve went into panic mode so
a spike in corporate bond rates creates
Financial instability because it makes
it more difficult for businesses to
access Credit leaving them unable to
fund day-to-day operations so this
caused the FED to want to buy Bond ETFs
which BlackRock offers through ishares
the FED ultimately contracted BlackRock
to strategically carry out the fed's
purchase of commercial mortgage-backed
Securities and corporate bonds so you
may ask why does the FED need BlackRock
isn't the FED like the government why do
they need BlackRock is this kind of like
back in the days when the U.S government
need a Chase very similar to but here's
why for its expertise in evaluating and
managing different kinds of debt like
portfolios of corporate bonds something
that's not a main skill set of the
central bank so what does BlackRock get
in return for doing this number one 48
million dollars per year for its work on
behalf of the FED number two unlimited
social credit number three power number
four influence obviously Larry Fink
doesn't need another 40 million dollars
but he does need the social credit the
influence and the power so some of you
may say Pat Central you know who cares
about 48 million dollars of course who
cares about 48 million dollars but does
he care about social credit power and
influence yes because that's how ESG got
its influence because of this
opportunity in his annual letter he sent
on October 20th here's what he said
Larry thing declared that a fundamental
reshaping of global capitalism was
underway and that his firm would help
lead it by making it easier to invest in
companies with favorable environmental
and social practices fantastic right I
mean obviously these ESG companies with
high scores are definitely worried about
the climate and the environment
absolutely for example Exxon they're
very worried about the environment
Philip Morris for sure they're very
worried about it but Tesla not Tesla
they have a terrible ESC score because
no I don't think Tesla cars want to take
care of the environment do you see the
hypocrisy this is when people started
saying what is all this ESG stuff you're
doing that's causing this Dylan mulvania
to get a Bud Light did Larry think cause
that based on what he did next with ESG
it was on him so it's important to
realize is why this took place BlackRock
drove a significant part of that ship by
inserting its primary ESG fund into
popular and influential model portfolios
offered to investment advisors who use
them with their clients across North
America the huge flows from such models
mean many investors got into an ESG
vehicle without necessarily choosing one
as a specific investment strategy or
even knowing that their money has gone
into one meaning you got a 401k if you
got a mutual fund you got an ETF you may
have some of your money into a company
that's one of these ESG funds in short
an apparent Black Rock LED Rush of
investors into ESG in the past two years
has been something of a self-fulfilling
prophecy at least when it comes to the
biggest such fun on the planet a
BlackRock exchange traded fund that
trades under the ticker ready esgu is
what the ticker is according to the data
from BlackRock and Morningstar so why is
this important why is it important to
have all this control in these companies
let me explain to you why because
there's voting going on right so the
significant situation in these index
funds vote could determine whether a
vote masses or not both for proxy
contests and for environmental social
and governance matters and even when
votes are not close the outcome of votes
can play an important part in
influencing the behavior of corporate
managers and by the way what I just read
this last part is from an article in
Bloomberg titled how BlackRock made ESG
the hottest ticket on Wall Street the
title should be how BlackRock use ESG to
control 88 of s p 500 companies why 88
because BlackRock Vanguard and State
Street combined are the largest
shareholders in 88 of s p 500 companies
so imagine these three are best friends
at the top and they get to push their
weight and say hey you guys got to do
this hey you need a little bit more of
this hey you better do this or else
we're not going to give you the money on
the back end when you need it or 88 of
the companies they can control so now
you may say well come on Pat like why do
we have to be worried about this what's
the big deal with this look in politics
a lot of times we'll talk Republican and
Democrats but the reality of it is
really it's establishment versus
anti-establishment establish is driven
by control and thinking they know what's
best for you so let me give you an idea
of what is establishment BlackRock
employs several Executives who came out
of George Bush's Administration and more
than a dozen from Obama's administration
let me give you an idea who that's
Obama's National Security advisor his
senior advisor for climate policy the
former Federal Reserve Vice chairman and
several White House Treasury and fed
economists why is this important because
there's something called labia and take
a look at what they're doing with
lobbying here so if you look at his
chart you'll see how much money they've
been spending every year on lobbying and
if you go to 2022 was their biggest year
and by the way a former recruiter from
BlackRock said it only takes ten
thousand dollars to buy a senator this
is a big business model to get laws in
there that they get to have more control
and influence over what happens with
Investments pretty crazy when you think
about it right so so this guy again goes
from bonds something nobody wants to do
teams up with Schwartzman then learns
how to restructure toxic debt then ETF
then 2020 fed needs his help that and
ESG and then all of a sudden even though
in 2017 he called Bitcoin an index of
money laundering and he said this on
Bloomberg in CNBC interviews you know
what he just did he just shocked the
World by the way by announcing BlackRock
applied for a spot on bitcoin ETF as of
June 15. so he bashes Bitcoin now he's
like guys you kind of got to start a
Bitcoin ETF because there's a lot of
money to be made here guys but let's do
it quietly let's make sure nobody sees
that 2017 quote none of us get
everything right but this is a guy that
knows what he said when it comes out
Bitcoin is what he's looking at very
weird very controversial but this could
be his next big move so by the way if
you're watching this right now says this
guy good guy or bad guy you got to give
the guy credit he went from where he was
at to winning in so many different
things especially after the big loss he
had 100 million dollars and he's
humiliated for 18 months then he comes
back and recreates himself and boom goes
to the top and gets all this money he's
a billionaire he's got all this power
but is this guy a good guy we're talking
amongst each other here talking about
him versus Soros and you know he's
saying Soros is like Joker you know he's
the agent of chaos and no no he's more
Lex Luthor he is the guy that's low-key
professional looks good on the outside
but he's going up against Superman who's
a good guy but at the end of the day he
used capitalism to get Capital to then
control the companies to impose certain
philosophies ESG you better have this
many employees you better do lgbtq here
what that's none of your business to do
that and it's got nothing to do with
climate and social and let's take care
of the world type of stuff because if
that was the case you should have given
Tesla a higher score but you're giving
Philip Morris a higher score than Tesla
because Philip Morris follows your
guidelines that's when you lose somebody
like me so if you're watching this here
right now saying look why would Elon
Musk call ESG on January 16th on Twitter
why would he say the letter s is satanic
I don't know so if you're a fan of Elon
Musk Elon is not a fan of what this guy
is doing but if you're a fan of George
Soros Georgian discount on the same team
trying to control a lot of the companies
in the market place they go about in a
different way but my biggest suggestion
for you is to go do your own research
and find out what's really going on here
so if you got value out of the city give
it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel if you want to learn more about
ESU we did a completely different video
on the history of esgn what's behind it
if you've never seen it click here to
watch it take care everybody bye-bye bye
foreign